not that close Kim Kardashian is staying
six feet apart from her first guest
since the corona virus outbreak
hey guys so today is the first day that
I'm having someone from the outside come
in to my home social distancing the
Twitter video shows the mother-daughter
duo sitting across from each other at
Kim's house
Lysol included are sitting 6 feet apart
having lunch together we went on a walk
6 feet apart and it really did make a
difference to get out we just went in
our back yard Kris Jenner then gave
advice to the fans who might be
struggling to stay inside still stay
inside Kim who sported a black hoody
hair tied and no makeup on shared what
she's been doing to past time you know
I've been doing everything from
organizing pictures making my kids baby
books every year I write each one of my
kids letters and I've been able to catch
up on those and write them letters and
just organize everything I've cleaned my
whole pantry and she encouraged everyone
to keep practicing social distancing I
just want you guys to still be
encouraged that social distancing is
definitely the way to go and what is
going to really make a difference here
to get us over this curve you know we've
been taking it extremely seriously and I
think everyone just really needs to
understand that this is temporary I'm
just trying to look on the bright side
Kris is not the only person who Kim's
social distancing from like that for all
my sisters the reality star shared a
throwback photo on Instagram of her and
her sister Chloe writing miss my sisters
but we are all social distancing and
staying away from
each other all separately self
quarantined it's hard but we have to do
this for our safety and for everyone
else's please do not ignore the severity
of the warnings to stay inside to stop
the spread of this virus we will all get
through this
hashtag together apart Chloe commented
with broken heart emojis writing I miss
you
Kim has been taking the virus very
seriously a couple weeks ago Kim had a
doctor over where she demonstrated a new
greeting oh that's it I don't have time
for - just one hey so you should not do
elbows because you cough into your elbow
so no more elbows she then wiped a gift
Chloe gave her daughter with some Clorox
wipes and I'm not down for that okay I
think we're good now I will give this to
my daughter again
[Music]